[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la circulation du côté de 19 s'accélère
en europe
plusieurs mesures ont été prises pour
endiguer la pandémie le royaume uni
impose une 14e voyageurs en provenance
de france 2 m et des pays bas en france
justement paris et des bouches du rhône
une passe en zone active du virus
les préfets peuvent interdire l'accès
aux restaurants ou bars et limiter les
déplacements de population
la colère des palestiniens grondant ont
su jordanie fier jérusalem-est en cause
l'accord de normalisation conclu entre
israël et les émirats arabes unis
l'autorité palestinienne le rejette et
parle de trahison
d'ici trois semaines les deux pays
doivent se retrouver à washington pour
entériner cet accord en échange l'état
hébreu annonce reporter l'annexion d'une
partie des territoires en cisjordanie
la biélorussie bientôt sanctionné par
l'union européenne depuis la réélection
du président loukachenko
le pays connaît de violentes répressions
de la contestation et des manifestations
qui se poursuivent tous les jours depuis
dimanche 6700 manifestants d'ailleurs
été arrêté au total 2000 d'entre eux ont
été relâchés et beaucoup affirment avoir
été torturés
[Musique]
monfort merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france le coc u19 a fait plus de 750
mille morts dans le monde partout en
force les mesures de restriction en
france paraissiez le département des
bouches du rhône sont classées en zone
de circulation active du virus et
préfets et sont autorisés à fermer les
restaurants les marchés et à limiter les
déplacements au royaume uni une
quatorzaine à tous les voyageurs en
provenance de france malte ou encore des
pays bas sera effective à partir de
demain les précisions de ciel bleu et la
flambée épidémique menace l'europe
certains pays du vieux continent
enregistre des hausses de nouveaux cas
qui inquiète
pour contrer ces chiffres préoccupants
le gouvernement britannique a décidé de
durcir ses mesures de restriction à
partir de ce samedi une 14 n est imposé
à tout voyageur en provenance de france
des pays-bas de monaco ou encore de
malte
vous verrez se définir vos vacances mais
vous devez être conscient que vous
devrez ensuite vous mettre en
quarantaine et c'est obligatoire j'en ai
peur parce que nous devons protéger les
taux les plus bas que nous avons réussi
à établir dans ce pays
et cela s'applique à l'ensemble du
royaume uni ne sorte que les quatre
partis du royaume uni l'ecosse l'irlande
du nord le pays de galles et
l'angleterre se penchent ensemble sur
cette question une décision critiquée
par paris en réponse jean baptiste
djebbari ministre délégué chargé des
transports a promis une réciprocité de
la part de la france
la france regrette la décision du
royaume uni et appliquera des mesures de
réciprocité dans le champ des transports
j'ai dit à mon homologue grant shapps ce
notre volonté d'harmoniser les
protocoles sanitaires pour assurer un
haut niveau de protection des deux côtés
de la manche
la france enregistre une hausse
significative de nouveaux cas selon la
direction générale de la santé avec plus
de 2600 contamination détecter ces
dernières 24 heures une hausse qui
s'expliquerait notamment par un
relâchement général selon l'organisation
mondiale de la santé il ya une série
d'explications à cette bosse elle est en
partie lié à la levée à
l'assouplissement des différentes
mesures sociales et de santé publique
qui étaient en place dans la plupart des
pays de la région européenne est
également un changement de comportement
chez les gens peut-être en particulier
chez les jeunes mais aussi une
augmentation des tests et de la
disponibilité des tests et dans
l'ensemble il est probable que la
propagation augmente dans les
différentes communautés en europe alors
que la propagation du virus s'amplifie
sur le continent l'union européenne a
annoncé ce jeudi avoir réservé 400
millions de doses du potentiel vaccin de
l'entreprise pharmaceutique américaine
johnson and johnson
bruxelles a néanmoins précisé que des
discussions intensives été menée avec
d'autres fabricants
l'espagnol renforce aussi ces mesures
barrières pour lutter contre la
propagation du coronavirus le pays
enregistrait près de 3000 nouveaux cas
en 24 heures c'est un record depuis la
levée du confinement really à cette
semaine les précisions à barcelone de
leslie cinglant en espagne désormais
ancré
2 mai dans la rue c'est la distance
sociale de deux mètres ne pas être
respecté cette mesure s'appliquait
auparavant en galice mais elle est
désormais commune tout le pays
le ministre de la santé espagnol
salvador il aa et danser également
d'autres restrictions les boîtes de nuit
bars nocturnes à et salles de concerts
doivent fermer leurs portes
cette mesure s'appliquait depuis le 24
juillet en catalogne mais elle est
désormais valable dans toute l'espagne
alors de leur côté les bars et
restaurants devront fermer leurs portes
à une heure du matin maximum et ils ne
peuvent plus accepter de nouveaux
clients
après minuit ils n'ont pas non plus le
droit d'accepter des tables de plus de
10 personnes
l'espagne a eu six annoncé des
nouveautés concernant les tests pcr
ils seront automatiquement effectuée
dans tous les nouveaux foyers de
contagion
ça peut être des centres sanitaires
centre éducatif mais aussi les quartiers
de l'espagne alors la surveillance
policière va être augmentée pour veiller
au respect de ces mesures
du côté des espagnols ils sont partagés
certains ne comprennent pas pourquoi une
fermeture plutôt permettra d'éviter la
propagation du virus
mais pour d'autres il s'agit de bonnes
mesures si ça peut justement freiner
l'épidémie en recrudescence des cas de
coronavirus également en guadeloupe 50
nouveaux cas supplémentaires depuis
lundi a vécu quatre personnes en
réanimation pourra éviter la propagation
du virus la préfecture recommande le
port du masque dans les lieux publics
ouverts
aucune obligation pour le moment selon
l'agencé régionale de santé le choix
étant laissée aux maires des différentes
communes et de puissants juillet le
nombre de cas ne fait qu'augmenter les
autorités sanitaires ont lancé des
campagnes de tests de dépistage plus de
21000 aurait déjà été réalisés pour en
parler avec nous en direct
samuel chemla médecin généraliste à
pointe à pitre
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors je le disais 50
nouveaux cas de coronavirus recensés
depuis lundi en guadeloupe c'est un
chiffre qui vous inquiète chiffres
effectivement inquiétant je la prends
avec vous effectivement certains
patients ont pu lui rapporter certains
cas de leur entourage dans ma patientèle
propre j'ai pas encore une masse de
patients qui sont détectés positifs
faisant même des téléconsultations avec
la métropole je peux considérer pouvoir
observer qu'il a effectivement beaucoup
plus de cas recensés en métropole ici en
guadeloupe
on va dire que la recrudescence n'est
pas encore extrêmement sorte
vous avez des chiffres vraisemblablement
qui ont l'air d'indiquer contraire mais
comment serre que les virus sur l'île
est ce que la population est vigilante
et respectent les consignes sanitaires
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
oui les choses se sont bien en place
progressivement les gens ont tendance à
respecter les gestes barrière à porter
le masque dans les lieux publics les
grandes institutions les aéroports
adoptent vraiment des procédures de
sécurité de contrôle qui sont assez
strictes depuis le début du confinement
et surtout depuis le début de la
deuxième vague donc c'est assez étonnant
de voir des chiffres qui semblent
exponentielle selon vos informations
depuis lundi je ne saurais pas
l'expliquer est ce qu'elle est ce qu'il
ya vraiment eu une première vague de
kobe de 19 en guadeloupe alors pas
vraiment on peut pas dire qu'ils aient
une première vague est ce qu'il ya une
deuxième vague inquiétant en cours de
constitution c'est possible il y aurait
eu un premier cluster avec l'arrivée de
antillais d'origine saint martinoise il
ya quelques semaines
mais depuis depuis ce moment-là il n'y a
pas eu d'autres événements majeurs donc
peut-être que il y à des informations
que vous avez je n'ai pas encore et qui
permettent d'affirmer l'idée que
peut-être lié et une recrudescence
pourquoi plus importante depuis début de
la semaine
qu'est-ce que vous recommandez vous pour
un invité
la propagation du virus comme tout le
monde le port du masque obligatoire à
l'intérieur à l'extérieur
bien évidemment ou dans le doute et même
depuis sur ce informatif qui est mat de
la métropole
le message est assez commun et donc
c'est un message de grande vigilance ce
qui était vraisemblablement et qui
diffuse sur toute l'île et dans les
antilles vers la martinique donc que le
message que l'on fait diffuser c'est
effectivement des gestes barrières
strict avec un port de masse avec une
distanciation social que se soit dans
les lieux publiques ou même en intra
familiales donc on alerte et on ne cesse
d'alerter nos patients le propre passion
pour ce qui me concerne de voir vraiment
sécurisé leurs proches et même au sein
même des cabinets de porter strictement
à mascat chacun chaque venue et puis de
d'autoriser personnes après personnes à
rentrer dans le cabinet donc l approche
de cette deuxième vague
on est encore beaucoup plus vigilants
est ce que vous craignez vous en
guadeloupe les arrivées de touristes
en provenance de la métropole où
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs sachant qu' il ya
de ce que j'observe dans les
téléconsultations que je peux avoir avec
les patients de métropole et j'en
observe au moins 20 à 30 par jour il ya
effectivement cinq films en plus d'une
consultation sur deux qui concerne le
corona bienvenue ce qui concerne le des
résultats qui reviennent positive donc
effectivement les patients issus de la
métropole sont possiblement vecteur du
coroner virus donc ça peut être
effectivement inquiétant pour la
guadeloupe
je suis originaire de paris mais pour la
guadeloupe de recevoir des patients qui
seraient originaires de la métropole
d'autres contrées et dadou devoir
importer un convoi des russes qui serait
méconnu qui seraient inconnus alors
arrivés et qui pourrait devenir un cas
contacts pour 1 kloster ici même en
guadeloupe dont on connaît la capacité
de diffusion de couy ça peut être
inquiétant c'est pour ça qu'il est
important de mettre en place ici aussi
au sein même de l'aéroport
les instances portuaires à un système de
contrôle strict ne serait-ce que la
température ou même des contrôles
immédiat par rt pcr pour tout venant de
la métropole d'ailleurs alors en cas
d'épisode intensif des pieds des mythes
comme et 19 aces que la guadeloupe est
prête masque blues test est ce qu'il y a
tout nécessaire c'est difficile de
répondre à votre question mais nous
sommes pourvus nous médecins de tout ce
qu'il faut semaine après semaine nous
avons les bases qu'il faut pour pouvoir
travailler
nous avons des gants en quantité normale
après pour le commun des mortels le
public
je ne sais pas quand tout cas ce que
l'on voit c'est un respect du port du
masque dans les lieux publics dans les
les magasins ou à coeur donc je ne sais
si le matériel est suffisant en tout cas
de ce que l'on voit les gens respectent
bien les règles et donc le matériel est
probablement au rendez vous et ce qu'il
le sera pour les semaines à venir je ne
peux pas y répondre
samuel chemla merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste à pointe à pitre en
guadeloupe
merci beaucoup
la france rend hommage aux victimes de
l'attaqué meurtrière au niger qui a fait
huit morts dont six français dimanche
dernier cérémonie aujourd'hui à
l'aéroport d'orly pour le rapatriement
des dépouilles en présence des familles
une attaque qui semble avoir été
prémédité selon les premiers éléments de
l'enquète avec pour objectif je cite de
cibler des occidentaux la taxe n'a
toujours pas été revendiqué mais la
piste terroriste reste privilégiée
malgré cela le premier ministre affirme
que la france ne cédera pas le terrain
au terrorisme et restera sur place
je souhaite ici affirmé que les ong et
l'ensemble des associations humanitaires
doivent pouvoir continuer leur travail
sur place car quitter le niger et pays
limitrophes
ce serait céder face à des meurtriers
qui cherchent à nous en chasser et à y
implanter leurs bases arrières comme ils
ont tenté de le faire roumanie avant
l'intervention française quitter le
terrain ce serait abandonner aux
assassins et à leur idéologie de mort
des populations entières
il vous vers le rond par la faim la peur
et le désespoir
là bas comme ici comme ailleurs
pas question de céder un pouce de
terrain au fanatisme criminels et aux
ennemis de la liberté d'agir de penser
et de s'engager
la france poursuivra son action pour le
renforcement de la protection des
organisations humanitaires partout dans
le monde et pour la consolidation du
droit international humanitaire
c'est un accord historique pour les uns
une trahison pour les autres les
réactions internationales pleuvent après
l'accord de normalisation conclu entre
israël et les émirats arabes unis les
précisions de clément hospital le
portrait du prince héritier des émirats
arabes unis mohamed ben zayed piétiner
et puis brûlé
l'accord entre les émirats arabes unis
et israël suscite un sentiment de
trahison dans les rues de jérusalem est
les palestiniens de la bande de gaza ont
eux aussi protesté ce vendredi contre
l'accord annoncé entre les émirats
arabes unis et israël il rejette ce
nouveau plan de normalisation des
relations entre l'état hébreu et un pays
arabe
cet accord est un crime contre la cause
palestinienne et c'est pour nous le
message que les émirats mettre fin au
conflit avec israël
cet accord donne à israël une chance
d'un excès plus de terres palestiniennes
de construire plus de colonies et de
tuer plus de palestiniens
il laisse également à israël les mains
libres à jérusalem est pour la basilique
du saint sépulcre les émirats s'il ne se
rétracte pas doivent être immédiatement
isolé par le reste du monde arabe qui
doit dénoncer leurs actes comme criminel
et prendre fait et cause pour le peuple
palestinien dans l'esprit du projet de
libération et de la position
palestinienne
avec cet accord israël s'engage à
suspendre son projet d'annexion de
territoire palestinien selon les émirati
mais benyamin nétanyahou a tout de suite
déclaré qu'il n'y avait en rien renoncé
le premier ministre israélien a précisé
que le plan d'annexion de la vallée du
jourdain et seulement reportée sur la
scène internationale certains dirigeants
à travers le mans nourrissent néanmoins
l'espoir d'une reprise des pourparlers
de paix au moyen orient des news crammed
flammes les nouvelles en provenance des
émirats arabes unis et d'israël sont les
bienvenus nous nous félicitons de cette
nouvelle bien sûr la normalisation sera
au bénéfice des deux elle est importante
pour les deux et la stabilité régionale
les deux pays sont nos partenaires et
l'union européenne est très attaché à
trouver une solution bi partite israël
suspendrait l'application de sa
souveraineté sur certaines zones de la
cisjordanie occupée
nous considérons que cela représente un
élément important car ces projets
constituent un obstacle majeur à la
reprise des contacts directs entre les
palestiniens et les israéliens
je salue la décision courageuse des
émirats arabes unis et souhaite qu'elle
contribue à l'établissement d'une paix
juste et durable entre israéliens et
palestiniens
je les dis au président trump au premier
ministre netanyahu et au prince héritier
mohammed bin zayed
mais cet accord a également suscité de
vives réactions de la turquie et de
l'iran qu'ils accusent le pays du golfe
d'adopter une attitude trop complaisante
vis-à-vis d'israël et d'agir au nom de
leurs seuls intérêts les américains ne
comprennent pas la réalité de la
situation des palestiniens en palestine
occupée
ils croient qu'à travers cette mise en
scène artificielle qu'ils ont
malheureusement joué hier ils peuvent
déterminer le sort de la palestine
les émirats arabes unis s'efforcent de
présenter cela comme une sorte de
sacrifice pour la palestine alors qu'ils
trahissent la cause palestinienne pour
servir leurs petits intérêts les émirats
arabes unis et israël doivent signer
d'ici trois semaines à washington le
protocole de normalisation conclu entre
eux cet événement pourrait modifier
profondément les équilibres
géopolitiques dans la région et ouvrir
la porte à des accords de paix entre
l'état hébreu et d'autres pays arabes
écoutez l'analyse de jacques benillouche
journaliste indépendant l'accord
implique certainement leur rejet de
report de l'annexion de certaines
implantations en cisjordanie alors
l'extrême droite est contente parce que
l'annexion ne l'intéressait pas
et les peaux parce qu'elle lui il
voulait une annexion total de la
cisjordanie or le projet de trains
impliqués l'élection partielle de
certaines implantations donc aujourd'hui
la l'extrême droite est heureuse elle
est d'autre part 7,7
cette décision va un peu rebooster un
petit peu le l'état de l'opinion
israélienne et de paix non américaines
parce que ça va redorer le blason de
trump qui est en difficulté
florence parly poursuit sa visite au
liban après sa rencontre avec le
président michel aoun et le chef d'état
major de l'armée libanaise ministre des
armées a accueilli ce matin le toner un
porte hélicoptères transportant
notamment de l'aide alimentaire et des
matériaux de construction
plus de 700 militaires français
s'apprête aussi à venir en aide aux
habitants par ailleurs sachez qu'un
deuxième ressortissant français a été
recensé parmi les victimes de la double
explosion de beyrouth qui a fait au
moins 171 morts à beyrouth où la
solidarité s'organise nettoyage des
quartiers aide aux plus démunis c'est le
récit de bassem chebbi un port dévasté
des façades d'immeubles arrachés et des
débris à perte de vue
beyrouth porte encore les stigmates de
la double explosion du 4 août qui a
ravagé le port de la ville et tous les
quartiers aux alentours plus d'une
semaine après le drame
l'heure est au déblayage pour une
population désarmée dont la colère ne
retombe pas dans le quartier de mar
mikhaël à trois kilomètres du port
roulier jacqueline tente de sauver ce
qu'il reste de leur maison le
traumatisme de l'explosion encore
présent il se demande encore comment ils
ont survécu
un morceau de fer de l'échelle d'un
navire a volé du port et a heurté ce mur
puis à rebondir ici c'est le morceau de
l'échelle il fait environ 170 180 cm il
a fallu quatre hommes pour le porter en
raison de l'explosion il a volé sur 3 km
du port à ma maison
pensons d'abord à un raid
jacqueline se souvient de cet après midi
du 4 août où elle a vu sa dernière heure
arrivée nous sommes sortis en courant de
la maison ne sachant pas où aller nous
pensions qu'il y aurait d'autres raids
contre nous nous avons vu des gens dans
les rues couverts de sang d'autres
s'évanouissaient près des débris de leur
maison le deuxième jour nous sommes
venus ici et j'ai fondu en larmes
jusqu'à maintenant je pleure tout le
temps pour oeil comme pour de nombreux
libanais la classe politique et la
corruption qui gangrène le pays depuis
des années sont les seuls responsables
de cette catastrophe
personne ne fait plus confiance au
gouvernement
les autorités affirment qu'elle ne
savait pas ce qu'il y avait dans le port
ces matériaux sont là depuis quatre cinq
ou six ans qui les avait mis là je ne
veux pas qu'ils réparent ma maison et
qu'ils me donnent de la nourriture
je veux juste savoir qui a nié ces
produits là mais dans ce paysage
chaotique la solidarité semble redonner
de l'espoir
déroutant ou non ils sont venus de tous
les coins du pays et se mobilisent pour
déblayer les rues et secourir les plus
touchés en attendant l'arrivée des
différentes aides internationales
on distribue des balles et des pelles et
des casques pour tous les jeunes qui
depuis mercredi sont en train de
nettoyer les quartiers avoisinants
on est entré en train de recevoir de la
nourriture de par exemple de grandes
boulangeries ou de restaurants qui sont
en train de nous envoyer ou également
d'autres ong qui sont en train de
coordonner avec nous et on a aussi des
individuels déjà les gens avaient faim
avant l'avant l'explosion de mardi
dernier
parce qu'à une crise économique et
surtout il ya un effondrement économique
est au liban dont il ya plus d'argent
alors que l'espoir de retrouver des
survivants s'amenuise la crise politique
fait rage au liban lundi le premier
ministre hassan diab a annoncé la
démission de son gouvernement
mais cette annonce ne semble pas faire
retomber la colère de la population
écoutez l'analyse à présent d'antoine
sfeir avocats à paris c'est à beyrouth
docteur en droit international
le procureur général de la république
c'est le procureur général plie de cette
poule à l'heure en principe c'est oui
c'est inspirant ce sont les juges qui
sont très qualifiés et compétents et
qu'ils ont la confiance du peuple
mais le problème n'est pas là le
problème se situe au niveau des
interférences politiques afin de
protéger des responsables politiques
administratifs des peut-être judiciaire
aux militaires en sécurité
fillon quels qu'ils sont tenus par une
certaine responsabilité criminelle
délictuelle pour administratives et
sûrement politique alors c'est ça ce
sont les interférences c'est toute la
problématique se situe au niveau de
l'indépendance de la justice au liban
pour juger ce que les les
les criminels de ce kit dans ce crime
contre l'humanité et pour les criminels
qui ont mené le pays vous désarroi
financier économique et politique et où
ils ont refait un autorise la mise en
place des sanctions contre le pouvoir
biélorusse un peu plus tôt dans la
journée la présidente de la commission
européenne avait réclamé des sanctions
je sais de contre-feux qui violent les
valeurs démocratiques et les droits
humains les pays de l'ue ont pris cette
décision après une réunion
extraordinaire des ministres des
affaires étrangères de son côté la
biélorussie s'est dit prête à un
dialogue constructif avec l'étranger la
partie biélorusse est prête à un
dialogue constructif et objectifs avec
ses partenaires étrangers sur toutes les
questions liées au déroulement des
événements en biélorussie lors de la
campagne électorale et après son
achèvement dans les rues de la capitale
les manifestations se poursuivent
plusieurs employés de l'usiné de
tracteurs de minsk ont protesté contre
la répression des rassemblements qui
dénonce la réélection d'alexandre
loukachenko
le président qui a rapidement réagi à
ces grèves
elle profiterait d'après lui aux
concurrents étrangers on écoute on a
besoin de retenir personne si les gens
veulent travailler aller travailler si
une personne ne veut pas travailler on
ne va pas la force et maintenant ce qui
concerne mtz maze et les autres pour
l'amour de dieu si vous ne produisez pas
dix tracteurs aujourd'hui et nous les
envoyer pas sur le marché demain les
allemands viendront avec les américains
les russes apporteront leur technique
ils seront ravis également il faut
comprendre que l'économie commence tout
juste à reprendre vie après la pandémie
et tout le monde luttent pour ces
marchés pour vendre tel ou tel tracteur
si nous nous arrêtons nous ne pourrons
jamais relancé notre industrie jamais
depuis dimanche plus de 6700 personnes
ont officiellement été interpellé en
marge des manifestations
deux mille d'entre eux ont été relâchés
d'après le ministère de l'intérieur des
arrestations dénoncé par svetlana atika
9 sky à la candidate de l'opposition à
la présidentielle appelle à des
manifestations pacifiques ce week end
partout dans le pays nous avons toujours
dit que la défense de notre vote ne doit
se faire que par des moyens légaux et
non violents les autorités ont
transformé la contestation populaire
pacifique dans les rues en un bain de
sang la situation est en train de
devenir critique
cela fait mal de voir ce qui se passe
dans notre pays ces derniers jours nous
devons mettre un terme à la violence
dans les rues de biélorussie j'appelle
les autorités à y mettre fin et à
engager un dialogue
je demande aux maires de toutes les
villes d'organiser des rassemblements de
masse pacifique les 15 et 16 août
écoutez l'analyse de claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
bon il est probable que les états
membres qui vont en discuter par
vidéoconférence cet après-midi émises
affaires étrangères vont sans doute
avoir l'idée de recourir à des sanctions
personnelles vis-à-vis du président
loukachenko et son entourage qui peuvent
toucher à des interdictions de visas à
des restrictions sur la détention de
comptes bancaires à l'étranger ou des
choses du genre mais évidemment pas des
sanctions économiques qui porterait
naturellement préjudice à la population
cela dit comme vous le savez il ya une
autre réunion dans deux semaines puis
ensuite un conseil européen au mois de
septembre
donc je pense que les ministres des
affaires étrangères cet après midi vous
restez prudent pour pouvoir évaluer dans
quelle situé dans quel sens à sa
situation évolue sur place en bref
sachez que les 32 russes aar et tessin
juillet en biélorussie ont franchi la
frontière russe aujourd'hui ils étaient
accusés d'être des mercenaires venus
déstabiliser le pays avant l'élection
présidentielle du 9 août
des accusations rejetées par moscou et
l'opposition biélorusse la 33e personnes
libérées ayant aussi la nationalité
biélorusse est resté dans le pays
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous retrouve dans un
peu plus d'une demi-heure pour un
nouveau point sur l'information rester
sur rt france
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous répondez à tous ceux
qui disent aujourd'hui que l'effort
militaire ne correspond plus à nos
besoins
les crises géostratégique c'est comme
les crises sanitaires c'est pas au
moment où on est dedans qu'il faut s'en
préoccuper
je pense que la france se doit plus que
jamais de se doter de moyens militaires
pour sa défense pour sa sécurité
le président trump a déclaré à plusieurs
reprises notamment à bruxelles que
c'était aux européens de se prendre en
charge de dépenses et pour leur défense
eh bien je pense que la conséquence de
tout ça c'est il faut que le concept de
sécurité commune en europe